If you've been thinking about buying
this little digital camera from the TikTok shop,
the one linked right here,
I promise you
it's worth it.
Not only is it $14
and there's a $5 off coupon,
it is legitimately a good camera.
I get that the price makes it feel scammy.
Like, no fucking way,
no way am I getting a 1080 p
digital camera that takes pictures.
44 megapixel pictures.
Like this shit, you know,
rivals camera phones,
the good ones.
The. The reason why the price maybe is where it's at
is cause the body is a little bit light.
It's made of a lightweight plastic,
so it feels very light,
but that doesn't change what it's got on the inside.
On top of the camera itself being amazing,
it comes with everything you need.
It comes with an SD card and the battery
and the cord to charge it and get it all going.
This thing, it comes complete.
When the box arrives,
you can take it out,
pop in the card,
pop in the battery,
and boom, boom, boom.
Get going and start doing what you wanna do.
Like just getting the SD card.
I was just very confused.
Like, the battery and SD card alone
is worth more than the price,
but now I'm also getting a camera
that takes really good pictures.
Like, I don't understand how it works.
I get that it feels like what, but it's.
In my opinion,
it's not too Good to be true.
So get it before it sells out again
cause it's constantly selling out.